hi my name is Hanley I'm currently
studying at certain grammar school my
question is does the Big Bang really
create equal amounts of matter and
antimatter if the theory is correct
how did matter win the first war ever
fought in the universe well honey you're
asking one of the hardest questions we
have today in physics why is there more
matter than antimatter in the universe
and so far we don't really have a good
theory for that we just know that our
kind of matter won that war that you
described early after the Big Bang so
we're still looking for the reasons why
one might win over the other as far as
microscopic theory tells us matter and
antimatter are very nearly exact
opposites we've not been able to measure
any significant difference so now we
have the same question that you have why
is there more of one than the other and
I think we await results from the great
Collider experiments like the Large
Hadron Collider which may possibly show
us that does not something that does not
fit the standard model that we've been
using for particles for all these years
so if that happens then we maybe be able
to give you a better answer to this
question